damn stuff and I'm the winner the GSA
Geography Bee I'm an 8th grading and go
to st. Mary's Catholic school in
richmond and i'll see you a tour of
richmond that which is the state capital
virginia and this is a picture this is
state capital which is built after
loveth Revolutionary War as the second
oldest continuously use capital and us
those design by Thomas Jefferson who is
also president after he designed it and
it was this is a Richmond with a third
location of the state capital during the
Civil War this valley with use has a
capital of the Confederacy and after it
had it has had many expansions that clin
the addition of the two wings on either
sides of the Me's horse the capital also
an interesting fact about it is that if
you notice on the roof in the main part
of it there's an a dome which is hidden
from the outside and
is invisible and those felt like this on
purpose and Thomas Jefferson's plan and
also around it there's many other
importance of government buildings for
state of Virginia with courthouses and
also there's a statue of board
Washington these are the falls at James
River which is what which is where
Richmond was founded before the
Revolutionary War back then votes were
used to transport cargo so the fall is
they wouldn't it had to stop and be
unloaded because as written ritual knows
bill to protect against Indians from the
west so the boats could unload and
because of this transportation it become
male roads would keep these boats step
unloaded here on shift on barter west
and this this is why Britain still has
many roads and bridges this routine
River as it can use down east into
Chesapeake Bay which is Wanda what the
largest estuary is on east coast also at
the stains room there's white water
rapids which are used for many kayakers
and also because of my pork parks on the
river there's made trails and many
opportunities to run jog or just walk
this is Monument Avenue which is was
built in the 1800's after civil war that
would commemorate six important leaders
of Virginia from the Revolutionary War
Civil War and eventually lost in the
20th century
Honeyman has built after Civil War I'm
right many of the Confederate leaders
and other famous Virginia's their six
statute stewart robert e lee jefferson
davis FML jackson in our garage this
money is a deafening davis who is
president of the federacy this road is
one oldest roads in richmond and as many
historic houses as you see on many lips
circles and also might there's many
trees as you can see
you